vous êtes boulanger vous avez 65 ans
vous travaillez depuis vos 14 ans oui
même avant même avant
pas du tout bon on était issus d'une
famille pauvre j'allais pas entre deux
de l'école je vais aller travailler chez
le boulanger les charcutiers d'à côté
pour faire un peu d'argent quoi ensuite
je suis rentré dans le métier à 14h30 en
apprentissage j'ai fait mon
apprentissage je suis monté à Paris
j'avais 15 ans et demi 15 août 73 et
puis bon on n'a pas arrêté de travailler
j'ai travaillé un peu à l'étranger ce
qui fait que j'ai pas cotisé totalement
mais mes annuités mes trimestres et je
me retrouve dans une position délicate
pour le pour la retraite et en plus avec
ce qui se passe dans notre métier
au niveau de l'électricité tout ça
maintenant une partie de notre retraite
c'était l'avant de notre fonds commerce
bien sûr mais maintenant qui envoie en
vouloir de nos fonds de commerce ils
sont plus vendables les banques
maintenant quand ils veulent étudier
seulement étudier pour
la succession à quelqu'un qui veut
racheter il demande déjà le contrat
d'électricité autrement ils prennent pas
le dossier alors à qui on va vendre nos
entreprises avec quoi on va partir en
retraite aujourd'hui elle va
correspondre à quoi votre œil
correspondance moi si je vais jusqu'à 71
ans elle va je crois que c'est 962 euros
938 euros brut
quand vous faites avec ça ah bah comment
je fais je travaille et puis on verra ce
qui se passe
aujourd'hui vous vous en sortez en tant
que boulanger
je m'en sors parce que j'en veux et mais
quand vous voyez que bon rembourse le
PGE
dans notre métier alors que bon d'autres
métiers n'ont pas eu besoin de prendre
le BG parce qu'ils avaient une rente
mensuelle d'un peu plus de 10000 euros
par mois et nous comme des des esclaves
on est en train de rembourser un PGE
avec tous les problèmes qu'on a en ce
moment avec l'électricité les les
matières premières qui ont augmenté la
farine moi elle a augmenté de
52%, le sucre il est passé de 78
centimes à 1,10 un euro 20 selon les
fournisseurs l'électricité l'électricité
alors moi j'ai un petit peu de chance
sur l'électricité parce que j'ai
renégocié en
mars avril mon contrat parce que j'avais
eu une mauvaise expérience j'étais parti
chez gazelle energie et puis du jour au
lendemain mais FAQ était passé de 3005
donc du coup là je me suis fâché il
voulait pas me laisser partir j'ai été
obligé de faire quelques menaces pour
qu'ils naissent partir de ce fait je
suis parti j'ai négocié entre temps avec
Christ et France qui a bien voulu me
reprendre avec une petite hausse de 15 %
donc normalement je suis tranquille
jusqu'en 2016 25 avec cette ourse
comment vous avez vécu les annonces
d'hier
déçu parce que bon il n'arrive pas à
régler le problème l'État mais pourquoi
parce que bon il y a à mon avis il y a
un problème de financement des retraites
quand vous voyez que les retraites des
privées on prend de l'argent sur les
retraits de privés pour payer les gens
de l'administration leur retraite c'est
quand même pas normal quoi c'est c'est
un scandale où elle est l'égalité où
elle est l'égalité en France maintenant
on parle d'égalité liberté-égalité où
elle est aujourd'hui vous êtes
à bout vous travaillez combien de dehors
par jour moi je me là ce matin j'ai
commencé à 4h30
j'ai fini encore très vite parce que bon
on m'avait on m'a appelé pour venir chez
vous bien sûr mais sinon je finis à
19h30
7 jours sur 7 et aujourd'hui vous en
sortez voilà vous survivez comme on dit
on arrive à équilibrer les comptes vous
rendez compte ce que vous dites vous
travaillez du matin au soir 7 jours sur
7 et ce monsieur me dit et c'est ça qui
est fout Thierry arrive à me dire et
avec le sourire parce qu'il est heureux
de le faire me dit j'arrive à équilibrer
les comptes normalement on aimerait que
vous gagnez moi j'aurais été j'aurais
été tellement heureux c'est vrai que
vous me disiez bah oui je gagne
énormément d'argent j'aurais aimé que
vous me disiez ça on est dans un métier
où c'est la passion qui nous fait tenir
notre faute c'est la passion la passion
de notre métier c'est de faire du pain
essayer de faire de la bonne qualité
essayer de nourrir les gens correctement
autrement dans un autre métier je vois
pas si j'aurais pu avoir la force de
tenir aussi longtemps et aujourd'hui
vous dites donc là j'ai vous avez 65 ans
vous travaillez depuis l'âge de 14 ans
aujourd'hui vous dites je vais marché à
71 ans à 71 ans
à travailler
980 euros par mois bon il est en partie
un petit peu de ma faute aussi il faut
pas monter des trous
4 ans
vous avez 65 ans vous avez démarré à 14
ans après vous avez des
à l'époque où j'ai commencé il y avait
des entreprises qui nous déclaraient pas
vraiment et bon ce qui fait que ça fait
un total manquant de 50 trimestres
vous êtes obligé de travailler et vous
en sortez pas vous avez environ 1000
euros de retraite c'est ça plus 200
euros de reversion j'ai 774 euros de
retraite de base d'accord et 76 euros
pour mes 6 enfants en plus donc on en
compte que trois parce que j'en ai trois
que il n'existe pas pour la société
vous travaillez depuis l'âge de 16 ans
et donc quand vous dites à cause de six
enfants vous avez pris perdu des
trimestres exactement aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas ils vont prendre en compte
mais nous on n'est pas dans le Lot c'est
ça on est dans les oubliés aujourd'hui
vous travaillez à 67 ans vous faites
quoi Janine alors je fais du ménage
d'accord parce que j'ai pas le choix
j'ai trouvé 67 ans
c'est extrêmement dur le ménage c'est
extrêmement physique et on est
particulier et c'est pas évident mais
bon j'ai pas le choix j'ai oublié
le 12 du mois alors imaginez 11 euros de
l'heure oui c'est ça
vous cotisez mais ça sert à rien bah non
parce que je récupérerai rien
que ce soit comptabilisé ça serait bien
qu'il nous redonne ça au bout d'un
moment quand même
à 67 ans j'imagine que vous auriez aimé
être à la retraite plutôt que
quand j'avais 55 ans que je travaille
chez Bouygues je me disais bon ben
bientôt la retraite dans 5-6 ans je
serais peut-être en retraite c'était 60
ans à l'époque mais bon j'ai rêvé j'ai
dû rêver parce que vous en sortez
aujourd'hui 600 sont les ménages que
vous faites vous sont les ménages
j'étais obligée bon j'ai été viré à
cause de vous non c'est pas vrai
une fois j'étais passé là et puis
j'avais parlé de on était de pouvoir
d'achat et puis j'avais parlé des
augmentations des frais kilométriques
d'ailleurs on en avait parlé ensemble et
puis
ça n'a pas plu à La Voix du Nord et donc
vous faisiez quoi là-bas je distribué
les journaux le matin 7 jours sur 7
aussi à 2h du matin
vous distribuer les journaux ça veut
dire que quand même c'est quand même et
donc comment ça s'est passé vous ont
appelé ils ont dit on a vous avez mon
dépositaire qui est recruté par La Voix
du Nord du groupe procès actionnaire en
Belgique qui a qui m'a téléphoné et qui
a téléphoné à mes collègues ils avaient
plus le droit de me parler j'étais une
chiante parce que je demandais des frais
kilométriques donc vous distribuez le
journaux
forcément
augmenter énormément et eux bah ils
continuaient à bien vivre gagner combien
à l'époque à l'époque j'étais ami
j'étais à 1230 euros j'enlevais presque
400 euros de frais de route
ils l'ont viré derrière on m'a donné 40
euros une fois et on m'a dit c'est une
fois pas deux pour un mois d'accord à
raison de 70 km par jour vous rendez
compte c'est énorme et derrière ils vous
ont dit
j'ai pas été toute seule là le 31
décembre le père de ma fille a été viré
comme
le sang est prévenu
les gens qui me connaissaient
du Nord qui est comme ça vous savez il y
a pas de il y a pas de discussion avec
eux voilà mais on peut pas dire on peut
pas qui si on peut pas virer quelqu'un
parce qu'elle a demandé sur un plateau
les animaux des kilométriques non mais
c'est leur dépositaire pour faire ça
d'accord donc le depositaire ça lui a
pas plu c'est celui qui a fait fermer
goder Amiens d'ailleurs
c'est pas la voiture
elle gère les dépositaires donc elle a
Somo à dire et elle ne l'a pas fait elle
a laissé faire aujourd'hui il y a des
personnes comme le père de ma fille qui
se retrouve à 61 ans sans travail avec
aucun pouvoir de retrouver quoi que ce
soit il a envoyé plus de 100 cv depuis
le début de l'année alors moi et rien
non mais Janine c'est incroyable parce
que je vais vous raconter alors moi je
vais vous dire Janine donc vous gagnez
1200 euros par mois plus environ 300
euros de ménage quand les clients des
sistes ou pas vous devez payer votre
loyer de 650 euros exact vous avez un
crédit de 530 euros que j'étais obligé
de faire pour acheter une voiture pour
faire le Corée Picard c'est ça voilà
c'est ça
130 euros de crédit en plus pour le
premier cas pour travailler
parce que je n'avais pas le choix il
fallait un véhicule
200 € de course par mois oui encore je
mange pas tous les jours
de carburant oui 50 euros de forfait
internet et téléphone ce que sont le
compte on le compte maintenant ça c'est
on est obligé de le compter maintenant
tout le monde donc c'est c'est vrai
qu'avant c'était une défense que vous
aviez pas avant aujourd'hui c'est une
dépense que obligatoirement 40 euros
d'assurance de voiture 26 € d'assurance
habitation sans compter la mutuelle
l'assurance décès des frais de rejet
donc janine se retrouve tous les mois
avec 700 euros de network
je peux vous montrer
euros de découverte tous les mois et je
suis obligé de de tenir le contact avec
ma banquière quand je vois que je
regarde mes comptes et que je vois que
ça commence à aller un peu trop vers le
trop trop négatif ben je préviens ma
banquière je dis surtout essayer de
payer mes prélèvements parce que ton nom
je vais me taper encore 20 € des 80 € de
frais etc
alors j'ai commencé à 16 ans
puis bah là je travaille toujours donc
vous calculez ça fait 50 ans que tu
travailles bah oui 50 ans que tu
travailles Janine et tu m'as dit un truc
il y a un instant je leur qui m'en fous
tu m'as dit je mange pas tous les jours
mais non je ne peux pas parce que je
suis désolé mais dernière cause je les
ai fait il y a deux jours j'ai même dit
à la caissière vous me verrez pas
l'adresse du mois parce que j'ai fait
mes dernières courses on peut pas c'est
tout est trop cher tout a augmenté que
ce soit le carburant que ce soit vous
allez faire les courses vous achetez
n'importe quoi tout est presque doublé
triplés donc on peut plus c'est pire que
ce qu'il y avait il y a un an quand tu
dis tu manges pas tous les jours ça veut
dire tu fais quoi en fait ce que je fais
moi de temps en temps je me fais un
petit café
moi j'ai ma mes habitudes je fais mon
petit lait avec un café puis je vais
manger ben mettons un BM ou bien je vais
manger un petit beurre en en
casse-croûte et puis c'est tout quoi
puis je me contente de ça c'est tout
soit tu vas te faire un bon resto à mes
frais quand même non non non non parce
que les gens vous imaginez pas sur les
réseaux après
jusqu'au bout de ce que je disais on est
j'étais pour le pouvoir d'achat j'ai
parlé d'une tomate mais je mangeais la
tomate sur une tomate de cœur de bœuf en
4 fois mais seulement je mangeais avec
un peu de salade un peu de thon j'ai pas
eu le temps de le dire alors je vous dis
pas comment j'étais il y avait du temps
non mais arrête avec les réseaux sociaux
tu travailles depuis 50 ans ma chérie
fait 50 ans que tu travailles tu viens
de dire ici et je te jure parce que tu
sais que je t'adore
chérie tu me dis que tu es à 700 euros
de découvert tous les mois alors tu as
une retraite de 1200 euros par mois
parce que c'est pas c'est c'est ça qui
est grave c'est que vraiment tout tout
est hors de prix parce que tu gagnes
1500 euros par mois et j'ai les frais
que j'ai dit là c'est pas des frais
c'est pas c'est pas dire
aucun cadeau pour tes petits-enfants
j'ai mes petites filles tout ça mes
petits ils ont pas eu de cadeaux de Noël
j'ai pas voilà c'est clair l'an dernier
ils ont eu la possibilité grâce à toi
mais cette année j'ai même pas pu j'ai
fêté nouvel an avec ma fille 24 ans
toute seule chez moi c'est tout voilà
parce qu'on peut pas on peut plus donc
moi je prends pas ma voiture pour aller
en Picardie pour voir mes petits-enfants
parce que c'est le carburant là mon fils
a fait grève cette semaine à la SANEF
vous allez avoir 5 % d'augmentation sur
les enfants je te pose une question je
te pose une question tout le monde doit
se poser son grand tes enfants et ce qui
t'aide un peu voilà je peux regarder ce
que je pense que heureusement j'ai ils
m'ont fait des cadeaux de Noël chacun un
petit cadeau mais je moi je suis pas là
je ne suis pas là pour que mes enfants
m'aident c'est ça normalement ça doit
être
l'enverste pas je veux pas faire
l'amendicité à mes enfants ce n'est pas
normal c'est pour ça que je travaille
pour essayer de m'en sortir toute seule
ça veut dire que tous les mois tu gagnes
donc tu rentres 1500 euros et donc le 10
du mois tu as plus rien ah ben là oui je
suis à moins de 700 et 74 €. comment tu
fais alors là parce que là on est quoi
là on est le 11 là je fais rien je fais
quoi jusqu'au 20 jusqu'au 31 janvier
rien ma voiture j'ai fait un plâtre 71
pour aller chez les clients je l'utilise
pas en dehors donc là ton plat tu l'as
fait pour tout le mois ah bah oui je
peux pas et puis j'ai intérêt à faire
attention heureusement je peux pas aller
ailleurs et donc là et donc pour manger
tu as déjà tes courses j'ai un peu de
course mais j'achète pas de viande parce
que ça coûte trop cher déjà j'arrête
c'est clair là tu dois faire zéro frais
ah oui 0 tu as appelé la banquière tu
lui as dit quoi tous les mois tu
l'appelles tu lui dis ouais je lui
envoie un message elle me dit merci
Madame depuis heureusement que vous
m'envoyez un message parce que mais bon
ben des fois il y a des il y a des
prélèvements qui passent pas parce que
ben quand vous avez le téléphone
supposons ou le DEF les tarifs sont pas
toujours les mêmes donc si vous avez un
prélèvement qui dépasse un peu
d'habitude c'est c'est informatiquement
c'est rejeter et vous vous prenez 20
euros dans la exactement c'est je te
jure organique quand j'entends ton
témoignages à chaque fois ça m'en fous
de travailler 50 ans aujourd'hui les
femmes de ménage tu vas faire du ménage
tu arrives tous les mois tu vis la peur
au ventre
est-ce que je trouve pas normal dans
cette réforme c'est que ils vont faire
des choses pour les futurs retraités
mais pour nous c'est ça on n'a rien on
est les sociétés
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui 67 ans
c'est jaune bah oui toujours
[Musique]
vous êtes jeune vous êtes en pleine
possession de vos moyens heureusement
qu'on est pas malade
tu es obligé d'avoir une voiture
qui te fous dans la vie j'essaye de la
revendre pour acheter moins cher pour
faire mon taf ben la voiture si tu as
pas l'essence moi je suis contre la
réforme de retraite
juste pour la voiture
pour aller travailler et que tu te fous
800 balles c'est peut-être mieux de
rester à la retraite la voiture je
l'avais acheté pour le Courrier Picard
quand je faisais le bruit
j'ai essayé de la revendre je suis sur
Internet
c'est la voiture
pas facile mais si je vends la voiture
j'en rachète une autre pour aller
travailler aussi
faut gérer tout ça mais c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire maintenant
ils prennent à chaque fois et c'est
inadmissible oui essayer de négocier
parce qu'ils sont quand même à l'écoute
de ce que j'ai il pourrait très bien
dire STOP 700 € de découverte c'est bon
aujourd'hui Thierry vous êtes-vous vous
êtes boulanger 650 en parler et un
instant avec Janine Janine tu as aucun
loisir ah non j'ai pas tout ce qui est
cinéma resto vacances est terminée
j'ai pu y aller l'an dernier enfin en
2022 avec mes enfants parce que c'est
eux qui m'ont payé les vacances je suis
parti avec eux et j'ai pu profiter de
mes petits-enfants mais cette année je
ne pourrais même pas participer de quoi
que ce soit donc je n'irai pas pour être
pour vivre à leur crochet je sais c'est
pas mon tempérament je peux pas et toi
et toi Thierry toi tu arrives à faire
des loisirs ou bien tu t'en sors
j'ai une entreprise qui est très
prenante
je peux partir deux à trois jours tous
les six semaines pendant les périodes
scolaires parce que j'ai moins de
travail et je me suis fixé ça quoi
70 71 70 71 encore 6 6 5 6 70 ans mon
entreprise qu'est-ce que j'en fais parce
que maintenant avec tout ce qui se passe
c'est devenu un vendable des entreprises
et vous avez bon déjà il y a les
problèmes d'électricité tout ça ensuite
vous avez le problème des banques parce
que les banques ont ils étudient les
dossiers ils vont pas prêter à n'importe
qui aujourd'hui c'est très très dur si
vous avez des trois fois des fois trois
fois quatre au x 6 ou x 10 comme on
entend que la banque elle va pas suivre
bien sûr et qu'est-ce que fait la
personne avec son entreprise et c'est
parti prenant de notre retraite parce
que je vous répète encore nous artisan
le bouquet en fin de compte qui fait
qu'on puisse avoir de reprise une
retraite correcte c'est la vente de
notre entreprise
et que nous créateurs de l'Union
européenne on n'est pas fichu de se
protéger nous-mêmes il y a quand même un
problème quelque part